io sono
un educatrice che lavora nell'ambito
dell'autismo autismo
ma che cos'è tutti siamo un po autistici
tutti abbiamo dei momenti in cui ci
estraniamo dalla realtà in cui facciamo
dei gesti ripetitivi come per esempio
spostare una ciocca di capelli senza
neppure accorgersene
per alcune persone questo estraniarsi
dal mondo è una condizione perenne così
come la ripetizione di gesti che diventa
una necessità per mantenere un
equilibrio
la variabilità di comportamenti
nell'autismo è molto grande
a me capita io lavoro appunto con questi
ragazzi autistici e io vedo come ci sono
dei bambini che non parlano che mi ci è
voluto più di un anno per riuscire a
fargli dire anche se una parola come
ciao in essere altri bambini parlano
però pronunciano delle parole staccate
che è difficile sono difficili da
comprendere e da riuscire ad acqua
capire che cosa mi vogliono dire altri
ancora invece parlano la loro
comunicazione e molto fluente però solo
per alcuni argomenti di loro interesse
quindi il nostro lavoro educativo è
molto difficile perché ci dobbiamo
adattare ad ogni singolo bambino e ogni
richiesta che questo bambino ci fa e
dobbiamo quindi tenere sempre presente
che ogni individuo è un caso a sé e
anche quello che per noi anche quei
bambini che per esempio parlano con lo
stesso numero di parole il nostro
comportamento che adottiamo con un
ragazzo con un altro deve essere
completamente diverso e quindi siamo
costantemente in gioco costantemente ci
troviamo in difficoltà certe volte anche
a lavorare con loro e le tecnologie
secondo noi ci possono essere molto
d'aiuto per esempio massimo paci di
questo sì progettare a tecnologie per
l'autismo è particolarmente complicato
perché si rischia di fare degli
strumenti poco flessibili e alla fine
inutili e nell'osservare come i
terapisti come cristina lavorano con i
ragazzi autistici
abbiamo notato come siano
eccezionali ad adattare ogni singola
attività alle specifiche caratteristiche
di ogni bambino è lo strumento principe
per fare questo è spesso se non sempre
la carta e la carta estremamente
flessibile perché la si può disegnare si
può colorare si può scrivere ma si può
anche a ritagliare fotocopiare così via
con la carta si può raccontare si può
far raccontare delle storie si può
chiedere si possono coinvolgere i
ragazzi nel chiedere indicazioni nel
dare spiegazioni all'inizio pensavamo
riprendere alcune di queste attività e
portarle sul computer sul tablet ma poi
ci siamo chiesti ma perché sostituire
uno strumento che già funziona benissimo
come la carta e invece non usare la
tecnologia per arricchire la carta per
poter fare qualcosa che oggi sulla carta
non si può mettere verba volant scripta
manet facciamo in modo che anche barba
market quella che abbiamo provato a fare
e fare in modo che ogni foglio di carta
sia un registratore cioè sia possibile
su ogni foglio di carta registrare la
propria voce a scalzarla in seguito ad
esempio volevo farmi vedere un foglio
che ha disegnato mia figlia matilda ed
ha raccontato qualche giorno fa sul
primo video
questo è il mio papà che corre mi cacci
forse si può farlo ripartire
queste ore mi cacci ok il poi la
registrazione ovviamente non è
fisicamente sul foglio e sul computer
che però non ci vede non si vede si
sente ma non si vede perché nascosta
sotto il tavolo è quello che succede che
la lampada una piccola telecamera
riconosce ogni è in grado di dare un
nome da ogni singolo foglio in questo
modo e viene associato al ad ogni foglio
viene associata una registrazione che
rimarrà associata al foglio e nello
stesso modo come vediamo verso nel
secondo video si può registrare sempre
usando questi strumenti che assomigliano
per del videoregistratore possiamo far
partire dal secondo video c'è un libro
sul tavolo
è un libro tavolo qui abbiamo fatto
sparire il computer l'abbiamo
trasformato ogni foglio di carta in un
registratore questo erano le nostre idee
come technology cristina ci racconti
cosa è successo poi quando ne avete
davvero usati con i bambini suo spettro
di sì ma stima punto come tu ben sai io
lavoro presso l'ospedale san camillo di
torino e al san camillo la nostra prassi
educativa è quella di utilizzare come
dicevi tu il foglio per scrivere per
colorare per attaccarci degli oggetti e
noi ancora prima di venire a conoscenza
della lampada abbiamo utilizzato coi
nostri ragazzi un registratore su cui
far registrare la voce ad un ragazzo per
poi in un secondo momento farla
riascoltare ad un compagno non presente
in quel momento e il ragazzo però vi
vorrei parlare nello specifico di questo
ragazzo mario il nome è un nome di
fantasia anche se quello che poi vi
racconto è successo realmente
nel momento in cui io gli ho chiesto di
registrare di descrivere che cosa vedeva
sul foglio lui era molto distratto
pronunciava delle parole distaccate che
quasi che non si capivano mario che cosa
c'è sul foglio pentola piatto forchetta
ma hai detto tutto
sì abbiamo poi verrà provato a
riascoltare con lui la registrazione
mario ma sei sicuro di aver detto tutto
dove sono gli oggetti li mali dove se
non lo spieghi poi il tuo compagno come
fa capire
sono quindi fate sì storie numerose
ripetizioni prima di riuscire finalmente
a far descrivere a mario tutto
correttamente in un secondo momento
siamo poi entrati a conoscenza di questo
strumento della lampada
abbiamo deciso di provare ad utilizzarlo
coi nostri ragazzi ci siamo subito resi
conto di come il loro approccio con
questo strumento era diverso e si sono
accorti che
nella stanza c'era questa lampada e
hanno subito notato perché loro sono sì
nel loro mondo però si accorgono di
quando c'è qualcosa di diverso che
questa lampada al posto della lampadina
aveva una telecamera e si sono ancora
più incuriositi quando io gli ho detto
che quella era una lampada magica in
grado di catturare la loro voce per poi
far minori ascoltare e quindi abbiamo
riprovato a fare lo stesso esercizio di
prima sempre con questo ragazzo mario e
ed era totalmente diverso mario che cosa
c'è sul foglio una pentola si fornelli è
un piatto sul tavolo
abbiamo poi riascoltato con la
registrazione e lui in quel momento
invece a differenza di prima era molto
attento guardava questa lampada
sorridevo nell'ascoltare la sua voce
provenire da lì era quasi proprio diceva
ma come è possibile questo e le volte
successive poi siamo riusciti a ripetere
che lui riuscito a ripetere tutto
correttamente senza necessario che io
dovessi poi magari intervenire per
aiutarlo quindi in conclusione questo
per me è stato veramente molto utile e
bello anche per i ragazzi perché sono
riusciti a superare questi loro deficit
comunicativi e riuscire quasi entrare in
empatia con questa lampada e anche per
miei giocatori è stato assolutamente
bellissimo perché ci ha permesso di
concentrarci sul foglio di carta
dimenticandoci un po quello che per la
registrazione
questo è quello che è stato per noi
invece per te massimo si è anche per noi
è stato molto interessante per noi la
lampada è un esempio di un nuovo modo di
costruire la tecnologia una tecnologia
che sparisce nel senso che non appare
non resta in evidenza vorremmo fare in
modo che le persone non debbano cambiare
il loro modo di lavorare se funziona
bene perché c'è una tecnologia ma
viceversa crea tecnologia restando
dietro sotto il tavolo e aiuti a
valorizzare ad arricchire a rendere più
importante il ruolo delle persone e
delle relazioni tra le persone e come
diceva cristini all'inizio infine conti
tutti un po autistici forse è la
tecnologia questo tipo di tecnologia nel
futuro accerterà tutti ad esserlo un po
meno
grazie